if you love Tiger King and really who
doesn't here are five other shows or
movies totally worth checking out on
this week's binge guide
hey I'm mark that was coming to you from
my palatial estate and the true crime
docu-series from Netflix is certified
fresh and if you want to believe all the
memes out there people cannot get enough
of this so based on what you're watching
now here's where you can watch next
first on this list is our certified
fresh pick and that is queen of
Versailles a character driven
documentary from 2012 about a
billionaire family and their financial
challenges in the wake of the economic
crisis much like Tiger king this story
starts out as one thing and morphs into
something else altogether by the end the
critics call it a timely engaging and
richly drawn portrait of the American
Dream and in just over an hour and a
half you'll spend more time talking
about it afterward than you will
watching it coming in next with our
under the radar picks is 2018 evil
genius the true story of America's most
diabolical bank heist
from Netflix this one tells the story of
what was known as the pizza bomber heist
from 2013 and the FBI's bizarre
collection of suspects those bizarre
suspects will have you seeing Tiger King
all over again and critics say it has an
intriguing sense of discovery and plenty
of entertaining insanity the four
episodes will only take you a little
over three hours to get through but the
memories oh they'll last a lifetime for
a throwback pic this week we're taking
it all the way back to 2005 with burner
Herzog's certified fresh' documentary
Grizzly Man this film centers on an
amateur grizzly bear expert who was
eventually killed by the very animals
that he spent years studying like tiger
King this film shows the beauty and also
downfalls of interacting with wild
animals through the eyes of what critics
call a fascinating subject
this hundred minute documentary can be
found a lot of places and is definitely
an interesting watch next is our rotten
show we love pics and that is going to
be conversations with a killer that's
Ted Bundy tapes on Netflix this features
exclusive never before heard interviews
from the infamous serial killer himself
you'll most likely experience a lot of
the same I can't believe what I'm
hearing
type of feels that you got from Tiger
Kang although critics say the series is
laced with troubling irony and is just
as elusive as its subject but with four
hour-long episodes it's worth a quick
binge if not for the quick history
lesson at least and finally for our
editor's pick we think you should
checked out don't f with cats hunting an
internet killer this three-part series
follows a group of online Justice
seekers and a risky manhunt to track
down a twisted criminal who posted a
video of himself killing kittens this
has a lot of things Tiger Kings fans
will love including colorful characters
and its dark underworld but warning it
can be tough to watch at times critics
call it an intriguing tale but with
questionable intent and muddled
storytelling either way it'll only take
you about 3 hours to binge and is a must
for the true crime completest ok
hopefully today's picks give you enough
to get to through your next view binge
sessions and make sure y'all come back
and check us up or more recommendations
and ideas based on the shows you already
love that's gonna do it for us here on
the rotten tomatoes binge guide
[Music]